[Musique]
alors je vous le dis très solennellement
ce soir cette cathédrale où l'art
bâtirons notre dame de paris l'une des
cathédrales gothiques les plus connus au
monde le 15 avril 2019 ce nom est devenu
celui d'un chantier l'un des plus
complexes pour les restaurateurs de
notre époque notre même de paris c'est
un monument emblématique de la capitale
et ça l'a toujours été
c'est maurice de sully évêque de paris
qui décide de construire une cathédrale
dédiée à la vierge en 1163 elle prendra
150 ans à être construite mais dès le
départ elle est considéré comme un
chef-d'oeuvre de l'art gothique
[Musique]
elle a des dimensions hors-norme 138
mètres de long 48 m de large à
l'intérieur de la cathédrale
il y a également le trésor qui est un
musée dans lequel est conservé un
certain nombre de reliques dont la
tunique de saint louis est un fragment
de la couronne d'épinés qui a été
rapporté des croisades par saint louis
aujourd'hui elle est visitée par 12
millions de touristes et c'est un
monument emblématique de paris
[Musique]
c'était quand même quelque chose qui
arrivait du fonds du moyen âge et qui
n'avait pas eu de grands accidents
majeurs en dehors du fait qu'elle avait
été mal entretenus et qui est donc elle
était en très mauvais état ou 19e alors
on estime que l incendie du 15 avril a
détruit environ 20% de la cathédrale le
toit a brûlé emportant avec lui une
charpente extraordinaire du xiiie siècle
qu'on surnommait la forêt parce qu'il
est fait 100 mètres de long et chaque
poutre a nécessité un arbre
le toit est parti en fumée et avec lui
la flèche qui m qui datait du 19e siècle
ce qu'on ne sait pas toujours une partie
des voûtes qui s'étend fonde effondré
donc il ya un trou à l'intérieur de la
cathédrale
mais on peut dire que la structure est
encore là et ça c'est fondamental parce
qu'on va pouvoir reconstruire mais que
reconstruire dans quel style selon
quelles règles notre dame de paris avec
ses 800 années d'histoire architectural
constitue un véritable défi qu'est ce
qu'on fait lorsque il ya plusieurs
strates successives et celle qu'un drame
de paris puisqu'on a eu des rénovations
importantes au 19e siècle de la part de
logiciels duc qui a passablement c'est
la flèche mika aussi rénover la façade
par exemple si les gars acheter les
gargouilles aussi des fameuses grave une
trame de paris tout ça est quelque chose
qui a qui y est bien plus tardif que le
l'édifice original xiiie siècle
plusieurs projets en circuler très
rapidement pour imaginer la nouvelle
flèche et la toiture de la cathédrale
notre dame
mais peut-on tout se permettre sur un
tel chantier ou existe-t-il des règles à
respecter pour définir des règles
internationales de la restauration des
spécialistes des monuments historiques
se sont réunis en 1931 pour créer la
charte d'athènes
ce document pose les bases des règles de
la restauration ils affirment la
nécessité de respecter l'ensemble des
styles architecturaux présent dans un
monument en 1964 une seconde charte et
créer c'est la plus connue la charte de
venise
elle recommande de restaurer les
monuments en s'appuyant sur des
documents historiques les éléments
nouveaux qui pourraient être apportées
sur un monument doivent s'intégrer à
l'édifice d'origine
la charte de venise un caractère de
recommandation il n'a rien de coercitif
mais la plus récente s'est pas la charte
de boeny ch arts de cracovie
créée en 2007 charte revient sur
l'emploi des nouvelles technologies dans
la restauration
elle affirme que tout nouveau matériau
toutes nouvelles technologies doivent
être rigoureusement testés comparer et
maîtrisé avant l'application
mais comme les traités précédents elle
n'est pas contraignante pour notre dame
c'est donc un architecte choisi par le
concours international organisé par
l'état français qui va décider du type
de restauration à mener pour mener ce
chantier l'architecte pourra s'inspirer
des restaurations les plus réussis de
ces dernières années on a deux cas très
fameux selanne a senti de la fenice à
venise
et puis à rennes l'incendié du parlement
il a fallu reconstruire ce parlement
dépouillé de sa toiture comme notre dame
ça a été parfaitement réussie
il a fallu dix ans pour le faire en
architecture tout est une question de
moyens qui s'ils dominent fin on peut
imaginer raisonnablement que la
reconstruction de notre dame de sa
partie haute et sa rénovation pour les
autres partis bien tout cela peut être
engagé d'ici un an à peu près
sommes nous encore capables de
construire des cathédrales comme c'est
le moyen-age la dernière cathédrale
construite en france des années 60 elle
ne ressemble pas vraiment à notre dame
de paris
alors avons nous encore tous les moyens
techniques et humains pour mener à bien
ce type de chantier nous avons 200
entreprises sur toute la france qui
travaille et qui oeuvre sur sur des
cathédrales partout en france
donc on a les moyens humains outre
effectivement les tailleurs de pierre et
les maçons et charpentiers et couvreurs
on aura des maîtres verriers qui ont
déjà travaillé au vrai pour la dépose
dans l'ensemble des vitraux les
restaurateurs de d'oeuvre de sculptures
les facteurs d'orgues aussi parce qu'il
va y avoir un traitement de l'orgue à
l'intérieur les nettoyage complet à
l'intérieur de notre dame
on va faire appel à des marbriers pour
nettoyer le sol
vous avez la restauration des sculptures
aussi la dorure un petit peu
donc tous ces métiers vont ainsi être
présent pour permettre une restauration
de qualité durable
on a les matériaux également on a une
des plus grosses forêt au monde pour
pour le chêne avec une production de 2
millions de mètres cubes de bois par an
en production en france et il faut
savoir que la charpente notre-dame
on a un besoin de 3000 mètres cubes donc
le bois si vous voulez en là nous avons
également la pierre il ya six carrières
de pierre qui fournissent le calcaire
pour paris la technologie permet
aujourd'hui des gains de temps
considérables pour les restaurateurs
par exemple la taille de ce bloc
calcaire peut prendre quelques minutes
avec une machine alors que pour un
simple travail manuel de finition
intérieure de pierres peut compter entre
4 et 8 heures de travail
pour autant le travail manuel demeurent
essentielles sur les chantiers de
restauration
quand on travaille sur un monument
historique la machine est un moyen est
un apport pour accéder
un étalage d'équarrissage si vous voulez
on aime bien ce côté rectiligne parfait
parce qu'on est sur le moderne et le
moderne exige d'avoir ce côté très
rectiligne très droit le monument
historique l'huile a vieilli il a hissé
usé par le temps il ya eu de
l'imperfection aussi part à part les
anciens vont travailler avec des outils
rudimentaires et créer cette
imperfection là la machine à ne sait pas
le faire ça et dans une restauration on
cherche à avoir quelque chose qui a de
la sensibilité encore une fois qui à ce
mouvement 7,7 cet effet de vague qui est
intéressant dans un patrimoine de la
machine ne retransmettra jamais cette
imperfection que peu à voir l'homme dans
la touche de modernité on peut
l'apporter que dans le dans l'aspect
numérisation des éléments quelques mois
avant l' incendie il ya eu une
intervention qui avait été fait à la
demande de l'état pour scanner numériser
l'ensemble de notre donc on a des
données numériques précise pour
restaurer on a cette chance
effectivement de pouvoir utiliser ces
données par le biais de
maquette numérique ce qui va nous
permettre de travailler avec des données
très précises et pour pouvoir aussi
utiliser cet outil numérique dans la
découpe dans le façonnage des différents
matériaux qui seront nécessaires à la
réalisation de ce chantier
le chemin est encore très long avant la
restauration complète de notre dame une
chose est sûre nous disposons de tous
les moyens nécessaires pour mener à bien
ce chantier
il reste à savoir quand est-ce que la
cathédrale pourra rouvrir ses portes
et surtout quel sera son nouveau visage
on